a lot of time has passed and we've got
married or have kids they have different
lives now Kellan Lutz shot to fame
playing Emmett : in the Twilight Saga
but despite filming four movies together
the cast isn't that tight anymore are
you so close to the Twilight cast here's
a group text message not not as much as
you would think
Twilight was a gathering of every cool
kid of every group in high school
musician the artists the the jock
cheerleaders so for the most part I got
along with everyone you know some of
them it wouldn't be friends in real life
I keep in touch with about half them and
while Emmett was at Edwards wedding
Kellan doesn't think he'll be on the
guest list is Robert Pattinson weds
longtime girlfriend fka twigs he's in
love he's in a serious relationship now
he walks down the aisle will you be
there and with Rob and Kristen and even
Nikki like they like doing stuff super
private and the Rob and I talk every day
on the phone though would Rob be at my
wedding one day I don't know if it'd be
in the forefront of my mind to ask him I
love the guy to death and we always hang
out when he's in town or when I'm in
town but I'm sure he's gonna be super
selective and I might text me after this
say hey if you're ever thinking about
time to not you know you better better
make sure I'm there yeah I mean - that
guess what yeah yeah but more so just to
support him and for me you know whenever
I get married I hope it's a destination
wedding
Kellie knees forever fond of the vampire
franchise but now he's looking to the
future his newest plague extraction is a
pure adrenaline rush and Kellan was up
for the physical challenge so what's the
plan get inside and ask them where the
codes are the fight scene how mapped out
are those you have the blueprint and
then the stunt guys get me in there to
see what I can do that move we've only
had six hours to do like the bathroom
scene which realistically you'd have
about two days to do so yeah I'm I'm
pretty well trained which helps yeah the
pressures on now it is it's ours yeah
works in the movies